تمويه العمل فجأة من
القوات الأوكرانية التي تندفع بمدفعية الناتو الجديدة المتوافقة مع
السرطانات البولندية ، معركة 40 طنًا
هذا اليوم استهدفت مواقع روسية على بعد
حوالي 30 كيلومترًا و 18 ميلًا ،
أطلقوا النار وأطلقوا النار
واستغرقت العملية بأكملها حوالي دقيقتين إلى
ثلاث دقائق حسبوا  لديهم
حوالي ثماني دقائق للرجوع تحت
خط الشجرة هنا ليكونوا في مأمن من أي
نيران عودة ،
هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي تحبها هذه القوات حول
سلامة أطقمهم الجديدة على رأس القائمة ،
إنها أفضل بكثير مما كنا عليه قبل أن
يقول قائد السلاح فاسيلي إنه  الهاتف المحمول
نحن بعيدون عن الخطر بسرعة ،
لذا فهذه هي
مركبتك التي تقودك ، نعم ، هذه هي مركبتنا التي تقودنا ، أرتيم تشغل
البطارية بالكامل حتى تتمكن من رؤية
ساحة المعركة بأكملها هنا ، نعم
هذا هو التوباز ، إنه تكنولوجيا عالية ،
لذا حيث يوجد تقاطع هنا هذا هو
الهدف هو لعبة starcraft هذه ،
يجب أن نطلق النار بالفعل
على مدرس رياضيات سابق كان قد تدرب لمدة أسبوعين
على السرطانات
لتعلمها.
ndly yes
بولندا أعطت أوكرانيا 18 من نظام السلطعون
وهم يشترون 56 أخرى.
شهرين في الخدمة دقتها
مما جعلها شائعة ، إنه
فرق كبير جدًا بين هذه البنادق الجديدة
والبنادق السوفيتية القديمة لأن بنادقها
حصلت على أنظمة GPS الجديدة
لكل منها  فرصة أفضل لضرب هدفها
، تأمل هذه القوات حقًا أن يتمكن نظام السلطعون من
إحداث فرق حتى الآن ،
فقد خاضت هذه الحرب في الغالب بواسطة
المدفعية ، حيث تفوق الروس على الأوكرانيين بشكل كبير ،
ولكن حتى مع الأسلحة الجديدة ، هناك
مشكلة الذخيرة هنا ضيقة
و  لديك ما يكفي من قذائف
إجابته بابتسامة صاعدة وضحكة مكتومة.
أود أن أحصل على المزيد من الجولات لإرسال
المحتلين إلى الوطن
[ضحك]